see I feel like marshmallows are like
camping and then peeps are like glamping
well that's that on that fam everyone
Emily here I am super excited for Easter
I want to share one of my favorite
family traditions whose team peeps so
I'm gonna gathers my friends at the
office and have them give it a try
there's two types of people in the world
those that hate peeps and those that
love beads I think that toasted peeps
will taste like magical heaven I'll give
it a try but I make no promises okay oh
we should have a pun about peeps let's
keep it up that's weird
I'm gonna take this blue one oh stuck Oh
first problem it's like a personality
quiz will be Pink's twinsies is this
what it is worth feel some heat oh this
is actually so disturbing it's like what
should go pink sparkly baby food dye
well when you put it like that now I'm
more excited I hope their eyes melt off
that's that's a little dark isn't it oh
my god I burned it
oh no now my Pete can't see I smell
something oh look Oh it's caramelized a
little I should like fight I'm excited
to be proven wrong I'm just excited as a
tease I'm gonna have to eat food Jesus
did not die for my sins
for me to eat pubes I think this means
it's ready if it's like sigh it's like
oh sorry oh oh okay oh you do you what's
happening oh I know we're not supposed
to touch I really am tempted you're
asking for trouble man oh my god hot
marshmallow is painful I'm just gonna go
for it I feel like it's ready Oh
one two three oh my god it was great
I would eat this for breakfast I have
nothing this up before there's a nice
like toasted shell and the inside is
very gooey mmm I'm so into this it's
kind of better but it doesn't taste like
anything
sugar air also just like look at that
like that looks crazy a nice contrast
mm-hmm and stuff yeah kind of like me
and you oh so you've had a change of
heart is that too much I'm in the middle
now because this is good I would I would
do this at home but be careful if you
try this at home oh my gosh you remember
all that when the lobsters used to come
from the dancing peeps
[Music]